last night New York Fashion Week wrapped
up and everybody is still talking about
Ashley Graham and her lingerie line
because she continues to try the
industry upside down with her message of
body positivity I actually had chicken
fried rice last night at tau and I woke
up feeling a little regretful because I
was like what does that the night before
a lingerie runway show but I do I worked
out this morning I'm feeling really good
no diet no problem only we were
backstage has ashley hit the runway to
show off her new line of holiday
lingerie I try to separate designer
model right now and just try to be a
model I am checking out everybody's
cleavage every line that I create with
additional it has something that's
unexpected and the unexpected thing that
you're going to see it as haulers that
are connected to the broad from
connected collars to extra stitching
Ashley added some secret touches to
avoid wardrobe malfunctions I have
stitched my bodysuit it's it's stitched
edge so I don't nothing open while I'm
walking anytime you go on a runway
everything just ends up going the leg
you just think don't fall and be fine at
0 but not under wraps the curves Ashley
made sure her show with the definition
of body positivity I believe that sexy
the state of mind and
no matter where you are if you're waking
up in the morning looking at your
partner if you just got home from the
gym I feel very sexy when I'm on the red
carpet hair makeup lemon in a sexy
outfit so there's all kinds of sexy in
my life